كلمات القائد العام الذي
قضى بوضوح العقدين الماضيين في
دراسة الحرب في أفغانستان التي
أدت إلى هذا القرار الآن ، إنه
في الواقع جعله غير مريح
بالتأكيد ، وهو أمر يتطلب
قدرًا من الشجاعة لقول
ذلك  إن تورط الولايات المتحدة في أفغانستان
قبل 20 عامًا
يمكن أن يتوقف في الواقع عن معرفة
وقت الاستقالة
إلى حد ما ، حيث قال إنه سأل
مستشاريه العسكريين عن أسباب
وجوب استمرار وجودهم هنا
وهم ببساطة لم يكونوا جيدين بما فيه الكفاية
وأبقى  بالعودة
إلى ما أسماه نسبة الواحد في المائة من
الأمريكيين الذين يقومون بالفعل بالخدمة
في القوات المسلحة الذين فقدوا أرواحًا
أو سنوات من حياتهم هنا في هذا
الصراع الذي دام 20 عامًا وكيف لم يجد
سببًا كافيًا لهم  البقاء
ثم يجب أن يغادروا وسيكون الأمر
بالطبع
بضعة أشهر معقدة ربما مظلمة هنا
للأفغان وهم يتصارعون
مع طالبان التي تجدد السيطرة بشكل متزايد
على الأراضي
وخاصة آرون  د فقاعة
العاصمة هنا كابول حيث يعيش التوابع الآن
بعد أن استثمرت المليارات فيها من
قبل الوجود الأمريكي هنا
على مدار العشرين عامًا الماضية ، اقترح جو
بايدن أن تبدأ
القوات الأمريكية في الانسحاب في مايو أول ما قد
يرضي حركة طالبان.  الموعد النهائي
قالوا في الواقع
في صباح يوم تحدث فيه أنهم
يريدون خروج القوات الأمريكية في غضون 16
يومًا غير واقعي تمامًا وجزءًا من
خطابهم الطويل الأمد بأنهم
يطالبون بالانسحاب الكامل
لكنهم ما زالوا يتفاوضون
بينما يطالبون بذلك باعتباره  شرط مسبق
لذلك قد نشهد محادثات محتملة
في الأشهر المقبلة خاصة في
اسطنبول يوم السبت حيث
يأمل جو بايدن أن يشارك طالبان
في محاولته لتشكيل
حكومة انتقالية
ولكن جو بايدن أوضح أن جميع القوات الأمريكية
ستخرج قبل
الذكرى العشرين  11 سبتمبر في
وقت لاحق من
هذا العام وبغض النظر عن
الظروف الموجودة على الأرض ، قال
إن الظروف هي وصفة للبقاء  g
في أفغانستان
بصراحة إلى الأبد لأنه لن يكون
مثاليًا أو جيدًا بما يكفي
للقول إنه من المقبول للأمريكيين العودة إلى
ديارهم الآن ، يحدث الجزء الصعب بالطبع
للأفغان الذين يتعين عليهم القدوم إلى
تسوية سياسية
أو إدراك أن طالبان سيكون لها
رأي أكبر  في الطريقة التي يعيشون بها الحياة
التي يمكن أن تسبب خسائر أكبر في الأرواح ،
يمكن أن تلحق الضرر بسمعة أمريكا
بسبب ما تركوه وراءهم ،
ولكن هنا أساسًا
القائد العام الذي يعرف
صعوبة أو قرارًا قبيحًا بصراحة
يجب أن تتخذه أمريكا  حاولت
الغزو ، حاولت الخسارة ، حاولت زيادة عدد القوات ، حاولت
تقليص حجمها
، حاولت فقط القيام بمكافحة
الإرهاب وحاولت إجراء محادثات سلام ، الشيء الوحيد
الذي لم يجربه هو العودة إلى الوطن
الذي سيفعله في غضون
أشهر وسنرى  ما إذا كان
ذلك
يتغير ديناميكيًا على الأرض هنا
بطريقة مواتية أو ببساطة يجعل
الحتمية
المحزنة لزيادة دور طالبان في
البلاد تؤتي ثمارها
ولكنها تاريخية  اليوم بالتأكيد
وخطاب عاطفي بليغ من
القائد العام للقوات المسلحة الذي يشعر بوضوح
بالإدانة
وراء ما قرره نيك بايتون
والش CNN
كابول أفغانستان